l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur les
conclusions du rapport d'information de
la commission d' enquête sur le contrôle
la régulation et l'évolution des
concessions autoroutières demande de la
commission denquête la parole et tout
d'abord aux orateurs de la commission d'
enquête qui a demandé ce débat monsieur
éric jean san et à sa présidente de la
commission denquête vous avez la parole
pour 4 minutes
chers collègues madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur m'en sers vincent
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est donc avec une grande satisfaction
que j'engage ce débat sur un sujet qui
préoccupe nombre de nos concitoyens
les concessions autoroutières depuis
leur privatisation de en 2006 les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
sont l'objet de controverses parfois
légitimes qui débouche aussi sur des
débats stériles
voir également parfois sont des débats
très caricaturaux dans quelles
conditions la privatisation et elle et
héritait réalisé comment les tarifs sont
ils fixés comment le nombreux avenants
ont ils été négocié doit-on en somme
mettre fin aux concessions c'est pour
apporter un éclairage documenté et
objectif sur cette question récurrente
dans le débat public que la commission
denquête que j'ai l'honneur de présider
a été créée à l'initiative du groupe
centriste
il s'agissait d'une part de faire la
lumière sur l'idée selon laquelle l'état
serait en quelque sorte floués par les
concessions en cours au profit des
groupes concessionnaires et d'autre part
d'anticiper la femme des concessions qui
interviendra dans dix ans pour les
premières et de formuler des
propositions cohérentes et équilibrée
pour que la répartition des profits
futurs soient justes pour l'état
les usagers et les exploitants tout au
long de nos travaux nous nous sommes
donc attachés à analyser les relations
entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes et a
retracé l'historique de la mise en place
du réseau autoroutier nous avons par
ailleurs cherché à évaluer de manière
bourreuse le niveau réel de rentabilité
de l'exploitation des autoroutes
enfin nous nous sommes penchés sur
l'effectivité des contrôles de l'état
quant au respect des contrats en cours
avec les concessionnaires les autoroutes
sont un bien commun elles constituent
des infrastructures de grande ampleur
est un outil d'aménagement du territoire
pour réaliser de longs trajets en
voiture nos concitoyens sont quasiment
obligé de les parcourir
on peut donc considérer qu'il s'agit à
la fois d'un service public et d'un
monopole économique et est il dès lors
souhaitable de la part de l'état de les
privatiser
lorsque le premier ministre dominique de
villepin a décidé en 2006 de privatiser
les autoroutes d ouverture partielle du
capital avaient déjà été réalisés depuis
2002 la situation budgétaire des sca ne
sait s'ils ne nécessitait pas
d'intervenir en urgence et la majorité
était d'ailleurs divisés sur le sujet
les auditions que nous avons menées nous
ont confirmé le choix qui a été fait à
l'époque a été de récupérer en une fois
un montant élevé un montant de 14
milliards d'euros pour réduire la dette
de l'état et financer de nouvelles
infrastructures
il s'agissait alors d'une décision
politique l'autre option était de
continuer à percevoir année après année
la rente que constitue l'exploitation
des autoroutes en assumant les aléas
économiques
le risque de trafic le coût des travaux
d'entretien il n'est pas question ici de
refaire l'histoire bien entendu mais
d'envisager l'avenir
notre commission denquête a estimé que
les concessions en cours était trop
longue d'environ 10 ans au delà de 2022
les dividendes versés devraient
atteindre 40 milliards d'euros à
comparer avec les coûts d'acquisition
des sociétés il il apparaît donc
impensable de prolonger les concessions
en cours et si le choix est fait de les
renouveler
lorsqu'elles arriveront à échéance il
faudra un minima en abaisser la durée je
n'entrerai pas dans les détails de nos
conclusions
je laisserai à mon collègue rapporteur
vassan delhaize s'en charger de s'en
charger je souhaite simplement
dire que le but du débat de ce jour est
de faire vivre le travail que nous avons
menées nous ne voulons pas que le
rapport termine comme bien d'autres
avant lui au fond d'un tiroir
dès maintenant nous devons préparer la
fin des concessions et faire valoir
notre rôle de parlementaire solide pesé
dans la décision publique sur un sujet
d'intérêt général
je vous en remercie mais si la parole
est à monsieur vincent de la et
rapporteur de la commission d' enquête
et vous avez quatre minutes monsieur le
président madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
un grand merci au président jean san et
à ce cher eric et à tous les
participants de la commission d' enquête
sur les concessions autoroutières
je suis très très heureux de ce débat je
suis très heureux d'abord parce que il
peut contribuer à faire en sorte que
notre rapport ne finisse pas au fond
d'un tiroir comme c'est malheureusement
le cas de nombreux rapports et puis
ensuite on a le plaisir de vous
accueillir monsieur le ministre est de
pouvoir débattre avec vous de vous
entendre sur un sujet d'intérêt général
et qui intéresse beaucoup nos
compatriotes
notre but a été et est toujours d'aider
le gouvernement à mieux négocier avec
les sociétés concessionnaires historique
pour favoriser l'intérêt général celui
de la collectivité et celui des usagers
alors dans cette affaire il y a un péché
originel le péché originel c'est de ne
pas avoir modifié les contrats de
concessions d'autoroutes historiques qui
ont été conclus finalement entre l'état
et lui même et qui était assez mal
ficelé et pas adaptée à une délégation
de service public confiée au privé et
donc il y a eu des modifications à ses
contrats notamment en 2015 mais ces
modifications surtout insuffisante et du
coup on a un espèce de blocage juridique
alors c'est vrai que certains contestent
ce blocage
ici dans notre assemblée il y a des
collègues qui le contestent il ya des
juristes qui le conteste mais je dirais
que le débat est légitime et qu' il peut
se poursuivre mais nous avons choisi une
autre stratégie
notre stratégie repose sur trois piliers
monsieur ministre le premier pilier
c'est qu'il faut mettre fin il faut
arrêter la logique infernale travaux
allongement de la durée des contrats
on a des contrats je viens de le dire
qu'ils sont mal ficelés qui n'était pas
adapté à des délégations de service
public
il faut il faut arrêter de les prolonger
donc ça c'est notre premier premier
pilier et nous avons constaté dans l'eau
travaux que pour les groupes vinci et
eiffage la rentabilité attendue lors de
la privatisation qui était une
rentabilité quand même importante était
atteinte plus de dix ans avant la fin
des contrats
ça veut dire que pendant les dix
dernières années des contrats
il y a matière à négocier des surplus
pour des travaux complémentaires sans
contrepartie mais aussi pour des tarifs
des modulation tarifaire en fonction des
véhicules propres du covoiturage dans
différents différentes choses
le deuxième pilier de notre stratégie
c'est le sommet des autoroutes nous
pensons qu'il faut mettre autour de la
table tous les protagonistes pour
définir enfin je dirais l'équilibré
économique et financier les contrats
c'est la pierre angulaire de toute
discussion
c'est toujours sur ce sujet que ça
achoppe donc il faut se mettre autour
d'une table pour discuter c'est
important et puis le troisième pilier
c'est les pénalités dans le protocole de
2015 il a été prévu qu'il puisse y avoir
des pénalités si le planning des travaux
n'est pas respectée puisque en fait y'a
un allongement pour groupe pour
compenser le planning des travaux et on
a connaissance que pour les travaux
prévue en 2015
ils n'ont pas le planning n'a pas été
respectée même si on n'a pas tous les
détails et qu'on aimerait bien les avoir
donc j'aimerais on aimerait savoir si
ces pénalités vont être appliquées et
pour nous il ne faut pas oublier de
préparer la fin des contrats donc
d'accélérer l'inventaire des biens de
retour et de s'assurer du maintien des
investissements notamment des
investissements
d'entretien et de maintenance il faut
aussi réfléchir à des clauses visant un
meilleur équilibre des contrats de
concession revoyure et partage des gains
et il faut aussi impliquer les usagers à
travers leur association et le parlement
les parlementaires ne sont pas des
empêcheurs de tourner en rond
nous pouvons être des aidants et des
soutiens en la matière et si nous
travaillons bien ensemble gouvernement
au parlement
je suis sûr que nous serons plus utile
et plus efficace merci la parole est à
monsieur jean baptiste djebbari ministre
chargé des transports
vous avez huit minutes maximum monsieur
le ministre
merci madame la présidente je leur
apporterai mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les autoroutes font partie de
la vie des français
pour beaucoup il les empruntent chaque
jour pour aller au travail pour aller
faire des courses pour d'autres
seulement quelques fois dans l'année
pour partir en vacances mais chaque
français je crois pouvoir le dire ici à
une expérience de l'autoroute c'est bien
parce qu'elles sont si on crée dans leur
vie si indispensables à leurs
déplacements si structurant pour le
territoire qu'elles méritent toute notre
attention
elle mérite mieux que les raccourcis et
des débats simpliste il faut peut-être
au préalable le rappeler nos autoroutes
sont un modèle de modernité et de
confort et de sécurité et la france peut
se targuer d'avoir l'un des meilleurs si
ce n'est le meilleur réseau autoroutier
du monde
nous pouvons en être fiers de ce modèle
façonné il ya près de 70 ans
la loi de 1955 conçu en plein boom
automobile de l'après-guerre répondait
alors au besoin d'équiper rapidement le
territoire mais depuis le monde a changé
et nous besoin aussi le paysage des
acteurs autoroutier leurs relations avec
l'état et les contrats de concession
sont bien différents de ceux qui
prévalaient alors les contractuels
justement doivent prendre fin de 2031 à
2036 c'est l'occasion de faire un bilan
critique de notre modèle de financement
et de gestion des infrastructures sans
complaisance ni démagogie c'est
l'occasion de le faire changer en mieux
de se demander quel est le modèle que
nous
le sénat s'est de nouveau saisi de cette
question l'an passé on en soit une
commission d' enquête sur les
concessions autoroutières présidé à
monsieur joffrin est assez rapportés par
monsieur de l'est je tiens vraiment à
souligner la qualité de ses travaux et
la pertinence d'une grande partie des
analyses de son rapport il fournit des
éléments d'éclairage précieux temps sur
la modalité les modalités d'amélioration
des clauses contractuelles que sur les
perspectives d'évolution du pilotage des
contrats pour les années à venir nous en
avons nous avons examiné ces
propositions avec attention et nous
partageons un grand nombre des 38
recommandations
et pour preuve près de 60 % d'entre
elles sont déjà appliquées ou en cours
de mise en oeuvre
mais il ya un mais nous avons un point
de divergence de désaccord même ce
désaccord vous le savez concerne vos
estimations de rentabilité des
concessions nous avons relevé des biais
méthodologiques puisque l'analyse
s'écarte de la doctrine retenu par le
régulateur dont les équipes d'experts
travaillent depuis six ans sur la
question
il ya aussi des écarts dans les
projections hors sac le sujet est
complexe
en cette période d'incertitude lié à la
crise sanitaire
mais entre la réalité des comptes des
sociétés et les chiffres proposés par
votre analystes on passe parfois du
simple au double voire du simple au
triple les résultats sont là aussi très
éloignés de ceux du rapport quinquennal
de l'autorité de régulation des
transports
enfin je regrette que le rapport
installe une fausse polémique sur la
question du plan de relance autoroutier
a entériné par le protocole de 2015 dont
l' équilibre économique a pourtant été
expressément validé par la commission
européenne en 2014 commission qu'on ne
connaît pas spécialement laxiste sur ces
sujets en d'autres termes comme à chaque
fois qu'un rapport a été produit sur les
concessions autoroutières il n'existe
aucun calcul ni aucune analyse qui
prouverait de manière robuste une sur
rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires plutôt que d'entrer
dans cette polémique qui ne fait pas
progresser le débat
il me paraît plus utile de concentrer
l'action sur l'action de l'état sur deux
priorités le meilleur encadrement des
contrats et la projection sur l'avenir
du modèle des concessions
notre première priorité c'est de mieux
encadrer les concessions existantes
jusqu'à leur terme
2015 a marqué une étape décisive en la
matière le plan autoroutier et la loi
macro ont permis de rééquilibrer les
relations entre l'état et les sr un
dispositif limitant les éventualités de
surprofits a été introduit dans les
contrats historiques et en cas de
surprofits les tarifs de péage sont
revues à la baisse ou la durée de la
concession est réduite l'état récupère
toutes les économies faites par les
sociétés concessionnaires sur leurs
investissements résultant des décalages
de calendrier ou des abandons de projets
le parlement a également vu ses moyens
de contrôle d'évaluation et la formation
considérablement renforcée c'est ainsi
au législateur qu'il revient d'autoriser
l'allongement de la durée des contrats
de concession les plats étaient
également en cas de défaillance d'une
société sur la sécurité la performance
ou l'état du réseau sont continuellement
renforcer et enfin et vous le savez la
loi du 6 août 2005 à créer une autorité
indépendante à l'époque autorités la raf
est redevenu depuis l'alerté qui rend
des avis publics sur les projets de
nouveaux contrats concessions mais aussi
sur tous les projets d'avenants ayant
une incidence sur les tarifs des péages
elle produit cette autorité à une
synthèse annuelle des comptes des
sociétés concessionnaires et tous les
cinq ans un rapport sur la rentabilité
des contrats
le premier rapport quinquennal de
l'autorité a ainsi été publiés fin
juillet 2020 certes les contrats
historiques représentent la majorité du
réseau mais l'état a aussi passé de
nouveaux contrats de concession beaucoup
plus strictes tout se passait depuis les
années 2000 respecte globalement les
recommandations de votre rapport notre
deuxième priorité c'est de nous projeter
d'anticiper de réfléchir à l'avenir des
contrats de concession
je l'avais déjà dit en tant que député
je reste constant sur la question
l'enjeu principal est de penser à ce que
nous ferons demain de nos possessions
nous devons le faire avec méthode ci ont
préjugé et précipitation et pour cela il
ne faut peut-être cadres et les grands
termes du débat
première question est de savoir s'il
faut interrompre les contrats avant
qu'il n'arrive à leur terme c'est-à-dire
renationaliser la réponse pour le
gouvernement est très clairement non
ce serait non seulement une gabegie
financière de 47 milliards d'euros une
entrave au droit des contrats et ce
faisant un affaiblissement de l'état de
droit
faut-il al'inverse les prolonger alors
je sais que certains d'entre vous y sont
favorables sur ses bancs je sais qu
intégrer de nouveaux projets locaux par
adossement pourrait être intéressant
pour de nombreux territoires de quatre
européens étant là aussi
particulièrement strictes je le disais
le monde a changé nos besoins aussi à
trop vouloir prolonger les contrats du
passé et nous risquerions d'accroître
leur déconnexion avec les attentes des
français
assurément pour autant ces contrats
doivent être modernisées et à moderniser
cela passe par travailler beaucoup plus
sur les nouvelles énergies peu émissive
mieux prendre en compte les questions
environnementales au sens large et
trouver des mécanismes pour une plus
grande modération tarifaire je n'ai pas
de vision arrêté ou dogmatique sur le
sujet ma conviction c'est que ne devons
pas brider nos réflexions nous avons
nous avons eu l'occasion au cours des
débats en commission d'évoquer les
concessions multimodal à des concessions
régionaliser des tarifs segmenté bref un
ensemble de nouveaux modèles ou un
nouveau modèle qui pourrait se
construire de façon consensuelle
ma conviction en tout cas c'est que le
concession bashing ne fait pas
progresser le débat
n'oublions pas que les sociétés
concessionnaires ont généré 50 milliards
de recettes fiscales entre 2006 et 2010
8 et plus que cela sur la même période
elles ont investi 20 milliards d'euros
dans le patrimoine autoroutiers sans le
modèle concessif des dizaines de projets
d'infrastructure au service des français
n'aurait pu voir le jour pour aborder
toutes ces questions et définir les
aménagements à réaliser d'ici là vous
plaidez monsieur le rapporteur pour
l'organisation d'un sommet des
autoroutes et sur le principe que j'y
suis favorable
il doit nous permettre de trouver
comment gérer entre guillemets la fin de
vie des contrats sont les plonger dès
maintenant dans une forme de coma
artificiel il me semblerait en effet
insoutenable de ne procéder à aucun
d'aménagements complémentaires dans les
10 à 15 prochaines années
nous avons déjà commencé à travailler en
intégrant le déploiement des bornes
électriques
les nouvelles mobilités ou
l'expérimentation de péage en flux libre
par ailleurs nous avons besoin d'un
cénacle où débattre des perspectives
de gestion du réseau concédé nous aurons
ces débats aujourd'hui et je m'engage à
ce que nous puissions les poursuivre
dans un horizon qui restent à définir
le parlement sera évidemment associée à
ces réflexions même la sénatrice
messieurs les sénateurs la question de
l'avenir des concessions engage dans les
prochaines décennies
c'est beaucoup le début même pas le
débat doit donc appliqué toutes les
parties prenantes les usagers
particuliers les entreprises les
collectivités terrier territoriales et
l'état bien sûr nos entreprises nos
autoroutes parlons doivent rester un
atout pour la france pour les français
pour les déplacements elles doivent
mieux qu'avant embrasser les enjeux
écologiques et sociaux de notre temps
merci à la présidence merci alors dans
la suite du débat chaque orateur dispose
de deux minutes maximum pour présenter
sa question avec une réponse du
gouvernement pour une durée équivalente
et dans le cas où l'auteur de la
question souhaite répliquer dispose de
30 secondes supplémentaires à condition
que le temps initial de deux minutes
n'est pas été dépassé je vais traduire
si vous faites deux minutes et une
seconde vous perdez la réplique
c'est à dire vos trente secondes et
ensuite au niveau du compteur si vous
reste quinze secondes
donc ça va être indiquée 15 secondes il
passera à 0 et on vous recréez dit ras
les 30 secondes ensuite on peut pas
marquer directement 45 secondes
j'espère avoir été clair voilà et
maintenant on va entendre notre collègue
même christine lagarde pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci madame la présidente alors
monsieur le ministre les travaux de la
commission denquête ont montré que la
rentabilité actionnaires seraient
attendus autour de 2022 j'entends que
vous constatez contesté ces chiffres
pour autant on observe que comme vous
l'avez dit les nouveaux contrats sont
mieux conçus puisqu'il existe des
clauses de retour en tout cas de partage
de 7 sur rentabilité pour autant ce
n'est pas le cas des contrats
historiques puisque rien n'a été prévu
lors la privatisation de 2006 et qu'il a
fallu attendre le plan de relance
autorités de 2015 avec des clauses qui
sont beaucoup moins nombreuses il en
existe deux pour les contrats
historiques contre 4 pour les contrats
pour les nouveaux contrats et en plus
ces clauses ne sont applicables qu'à
partir de seuil de déclenchement
et puisque vous
crédité vous donner foi aux documents de
l'autorité de la régulation dans son
rapport de juillet 2000 2020 elle
qualifie le seuil de déclenchement du de
hautement improbables
donc voilà il nous amène cela nous amène
aujourd'hui à vous poser un certain
nombre de questions notamment pour
arriver à trouver des réponses qui
permettrait de rééquilibrer ce partage
de la sueur rentabilité donc le
gouvernement va-t-il donner à la rt les
moyens de collecter auprès des sociétés
d'autoroutes les informations
nécessaires à l'analyse des variations
de la rentabilité depuis 2002 le parle
le gouvernement va-t-il soutenir la
proposition de loi qui a été déposé par
le président du groupe l'est républicain
qui vient durcir les clauses prévues
pour les contrats historiques à savoir
les clauses de péage endogène et deux
durées endogène et si ce n'est pas le
cas quelles sont les solutions du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole merci madame la
présidente monsieur le sénateur madame
la sénatrice la varde peut-être réponse
en quelques points
d'abord revenir sur l'hypothétique sur
rentabilité pour dire ou pour citer plus
précisément les chiffres de la rt qui
avec la méthode et les conclusions qu'il
a présenté lors du rapport quinquennal
de l'été 2020 apparaît ce divergentes
avec les chiffres de la mission pour
redonner les chip tolère t les
rentabilité des contrats des sociétés
historiques puisque souvent c'est à elle
qu'on fait référence sont estimés autour
de 7 8% dans une fourchette oscillant
entre 6,4 et 9 2%
il est aussi indiqué dans ce rapport que
les taux de rentabilité interne ont
enregistré une évolution favorable mais
modérée depuis 2010 est due aux
conséquences ou en tout cas la situation
macroéconomique par ailleurs et vous le
savez le plan de relance et autoroutier
de 2015 n'a pas engendré de
surcompensation
les investissements prévus les 3 2
milliards ont essentiellement porté sur
des élargissements de section et la
construction ou la modification des
changeurs l' équilibre de la
compensation dans le plan de relance
autoroutier a été confirmée je le disais
en propos liminaire par la commission
lors de sa décision du 24 octobre
dernier et
c'est la sous-estimation du théorie par
le rapport qui conduit à conclure à une
surcompensation chiffré à quatre
milliards soit plus que la valeur des
investissements du plan ce qui n'est pas
compréhensible sur les moyens de la rt
pour en porter d'abord sur les
mécanismes limitant les surprofits dans
les contrats historiques puisqu'ils ont
aussi été installés pour dire simplement
que en cas de sur performance économique
sur la période d'allongement du contrat
allait tarifs de péages soient revus à
la baisse soit la durée de la concession
est réduite et que par ailleurs le gain
financier issu de tout décalage dans
l'exécution des investissements par ces
sociétés est également est intégralement
restitué au concédant nous avons donc là
un on dirait une structure un dispositif
qui nous permet de bien limiter ou de
bien encadrer l'équilibré économique des
contrats sur les moyens de les alerter
vous savez clerté aujourd'hui embrasse
des compétences beaucoup plus large et
qu'elle est tout à fait à la hauteur de
1000 la chaussée merci monsieur le
ministre à madame la vad vous avez 59
secondes
oui alors j'ai bien écouté monsieur le
ministre et j'avais pris la peine en
préambule de dire qu'ils ne partageaient
pas notre constat sur l'art sur
rentabilité mais que je l'invité quand
même à nous propose à nous dire ce qu'il
ferait dans le futur et là j'avoue je
n'ai eu absolument aucune réponse à mes
questions qui étaient pourtant assez
précises puisque je vous donnais déjà
des des outils pour justement demain que
ce soit dans le cadre du non
renouvellement des concessions ou si
jamais il s'avérait qu'effectivement les
chiffres de la commission denquête
s'avérer exacte et là je me suis
pourtant appuyée sur l'auto le rapport
de l'autorité de régulation de juillet
2020 qui sur les clauses que vous nous
avez décrite comme étant des clauses qui
doivent permettre justement de prévoir
entre guillemets un retour à bonne
fortune du concédant et surtout derrière
le concédant de l'usagé l'autorité dit
elle même elle l'écrit tandis que celui
des clauses de durée endogène semble
hautement improbable
c'est à dire qu'il se produit uniquement
dans des cas que l'autorité juge
invraisemblable
donc il me semble que la lecture était
perfectible
merci la parole est à monsieur pierre
médevielle pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
merci maman le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
l'évolution des concessions
autoroutières est régulièrement évoquée
en france depuis des décennies par tous
les bords politiques en 2015 alors
membre du groupe de travail sur les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
j'ai refusé de signer les conclusions
présentées par le groupe pour une raison
simple le calcul virtuelle de la
rentabilité en laisse tenter par
l'autorité de la concurrence on mettait
deux éléments essentiels
le montant du rachat autour de 22
milliards
il a reprise de la dette pour plus de 17
milliards excusez du peu
cette présentation était donc erroné
pour évaluer la rentabilité réelle des
concessions je n'aurais pas bien sûr en
cause de la rentabilité mais la réalité
est le montant de cette manne financière
qui a également dire que le rapport de
la commission ne tient pas compte de
l'inflation depuis 2006
d'autres ont rappelé que la
privatisation date de 15 ans on ne parle
pas non plus des pertes occasionnées par
le confinement
je rappelle aussi que le prolongement
des concessions décriée est due à une
volonté de l'état n'ayant pas pu honorer
ses engagements en matière d'extension
des raisons
comme toujours on se pose donc la
question de la fin des concessions et du
retour de l'état dans la gestion des
autoroutes
le rapport d'enquêté clair le rachat des
concessions vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre donnerait autour de 50
milliards d'euros
outre le fait que nous traversons une
crise majeure qui demande des moyens
financiers importants
j'identifie de problème supplémentaire
celui des recettes et du risque de non
affectation de ses recettes pour
l'entretien entre raison qui est un des
meilleurs d'europe
rappelons que l'état avant la
privatisation percevait une manne très
faible ne les parts des sociétés
publiques qui exploitait la réflexion
autour de contrats plus équilibrée me
paraît ainsi être la proposition la plus
juste la crédibilité de l'état français
et de sa parole est en jeu il faut
garder en tête que merci entre temps je
suis désolé
oui après nous avons d'autres débats
monsieur le ministre pour la réponse
donc voila merci madame la présidente ne
faisait messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs peut-être trois points un
point d'abord sur le bilan objectif que
vous avez partiellement tracé mais qui
est un bilan positif du modèle concessif
on est quand même passé en 70 ans en
france de 80 kg mais de tout à plus de
9000 km qui sont bien entretenues
sécurisé sécuritaire et qui permettent
et qui ont permis de moderniser de
désenclaver avec succès un certain
nombre de territoires au moment où la
route l'autoroute était le moyen
plébiscité sur l'équilibré économique
d'une manière générale des contrats je
ne reviendrai pas nous enlever la
discussion préalablement et puis j'ai
essayé d'évoquer les choses de la façon
la plus circonspecte possible lors de
mon propos liminaire peut-être dire
qu'en plus de l'encadrement le
confinement l'époque récente finalement
nous apprend mais nous savions déjà
c'était déjà le cas en 2008 que le
risque de trafic et un ace qui se
réalise
y compris côté les concessions
autoroutières vous avez cité des
éléments qui sont en faveur la plus
faible inflation par exemple ou
l'environnement de taux bas
mais il ya également des événements des
risques réels pris en compte dans la
construction des théories qui se réalise
et le k2 du risque de trafic due à la
très grande diminution du trafic des
suites du confinement qui a vu les
sociétés père de plusieurs milliards
d'euros sur la suite d'abord dire oh
dear notre ouverture à la réflexion à la
réflexion sur le futur modèle de gestion
des autoroutes concédées des réseaux au
sens large la place de l'état les
différents modèles qui pourraient être
créés qui vous répondrait davantage
peut-être à un modèle moderne de gestion
de nos impressions public redire à
nouveau qui à mon sens par là des
infrastructures à l'horizon 2040 2050
avec un très grand rééquilibrage de la
route avec d'autres modes de transport
n'est pas tout à fait impossible d'avoir
une conception sur des nouvelles
concessions qui seraient davantage
multimodal en tout cas tournés vers les
enjeux écologiques et sociaux que j'ai
pu cités précédemment et j'en termine
par la madame est présidente pour être
dans les temps
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
jacques fernique pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires
donc monsieur le ministère collègues le
verdissement de nos autoroutes
une nécessité qui loin d'être nouvelles
s'imposent aujourd'hui fermement
il est essentiel que les
concessionnaires encourage les mobilités
à faible empreinte carbone mais sans
reproduire les erreurs passées
le soutien des mobilités écologiquement
vertueuse doit se faire sans
contrepartie financière supplémentaire
car personne ne contestera la
rentabilité économique des sociétés
d'autoroutes je crois pas que ça soit
faire de la concession bashing
démagogique que de dire que la hausse de
leurs profits pour la décennie à venir
est indéniable 1 selon les projections
du rapport la rentabilité actionnaires
sera atteinte dès 2022 et on parle de
l'ordre de 40 milliards d'euros d'ici à
2030 6 pour les dividendes distribués
donc vous ça a été dit et je pense que
voici l'argument que concédant doit
avancer au cours de la prochaine
négociation pour verdir les tarifs
orienter les investissements pour la
décarbonation sans compensation nouvelle
la prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux doit être une
obligation contractuelle
c'est le principe même de l'éco
conditionnalité pour préparer l'avenir
l'équipe des contrats en faveur de
l'intérêt public doit être instaurée il
s'agit de définir concrètement la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des concessionnaires
dans le prolongement de la loi
d'orientation de mobilité le déploiement
des bornes de recharge électrique doit
passer à la vitesse supérieure
l'aménagement des voies dédiées au
covoiturage au transport collectif doit
avancer nettement des incitations
tarifaires significative être proposée
aux véhicules les plus fortes vertueux
en particulier pour les poids lourds
d'ailleurs les tronçons autoroutiers
public propose d'ores et déjà une
réduction tarifaire importante aux
véhicules électriques
ma question est donc la suivante comment
amener les concessionnaires un cahier
des charges ambitieux de décarbonation
pour garantir que ces acteurs
incontournables prenne réellement en
compte l'objectif de l'accord de paris
merci monsieur le ministre c'est merci
madame la présidente ont rapidement dire
que l'enjeu écologique a été pris en
tout cas le tournoi a été pris au début
des années 2000 s'agissant du paquet
vert autoroutier que
simplement dans les plans de relance de
2015 et la demande 2018 plus de 400
millions d'euros cumulés ont été
consacrés à ces investissements
à l'époque historique qui ont permis de
réaliser réalisé par don des ouvrages
protégeant la biodiversité d' améliorer
l'assainissement ou encore de supprimer
des points noirs du bruit du bruit pour
autant vous avez raison de le dire il
faut aller plus loin il ya des
expérimentations qui sont aujourd'hui
pleinement satisfaisante je pense
notamment aux expérimentations autour
des flux libre
nous avons lancé en lien avec les
concessions un grand plan de déploiement
des bornes de recharge électrique
nous aurons la fin de l'année et plus de
60% des airs de recharge sur le réseau
concédé qui seront dotés de bornes à
grande puissance de recharge et je crois
que cela mettra contrat d un contrat
périmètre des contrats constant et je
crois que cela matérialise assez bien le
co investissement équilibrée entre
l'état et les sociétés concessionnaires
dans ce set grande transformation
écologique que nous accompagnons
aujourd'hui quand je vais vous le dire
toutes les propositions que nous avons
reçu les débats que nous avons pu avoir
avec les élus intègre pleinement la
dimension et l'intégration
environnementale et je sais les
concessionnaires parfaitement engagé sur
le sujet merci monsieur fernique
merci donc la parole et à madame
patricia sillinger pour le groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes se dit indépendant merci
madame la présidente nationaux ministre
avec un maillage autoroutier de près de
9500 km la france avec nos voisins
allemands se situe en pôle position des
pays européens en terme de longueur de
réseaux symbole du modernisme des trente
glorieuses
ce réseau dont 90% a été concédée à d
sociétés à capitaux privés a perdu de sa
superbe
en effet notre parc autoroutier s'il est
nécessaire et performant pour nos
usagers doit se réinventer notamment
pour se conformer aux nouvelles
exigences environnementales
pourtant nous sommes défavorables à
l'arrêt re-nationalisation de nos
autoroutes en rachetant les concessions
dont les premières arrivent à échéance
en 2031 l'état ne pourrait se permettre
de gonfler son déficit de 50 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
nous sommes en revanche favorables à un
rééquilibrage des relations en
entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires notamment en termes
d'accompagnement en direction des
mobilités des investissements
conséquents pourrait être mise en place
en faveur du covoiturage des parkings
relais et des transports collectifs
le projet de loi climat résilience que
nous examinerons prochainement sera un
véhicule pertinent pour proposer ses
nouvelles alternatives durables
monsieur le ministre comment comptez
vous accompagner les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute pour
qu'elles puissent se conformer à de
nouvelles exigences
merci vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci madame la présidente
la sénatrice peut-être qu'un exemple de
ce que nous faisons sur le véhicule
électrique c'est un bon exemple
d'exigence réciproque entre et le
respect du droit des contrats entre
l'état et les sociétés concessionnaires
vous savez nous avons lancé un grand
plan de déploiement des bornes de
l'électrique j'en parlais instant à la
fois sur les réseaux concédés non
concédé et plus largement partout en
france de manière à permettre
l'itinérance un élément essentiel à la
confiance des consommateurs
je lisais d'ici à la fin d'année nous
aurons 60% des airs des réseaux concédés
qui seront couvertes et d'ici fin 2022
nous avons 100 % des est recouverte d'un
même temps nos maisons évidemment ce
chantier sur le réseau routier non
concédé
je disais équilibre économique parce que
dans cette petite a fait entre
guillemets l'état investit 100 millions
d'euros du plan de relance c'est
important les sociétés concessionnaires
investi 500 millions d'euros et dans une
temporalité dans une durée très courte
avec tous les sujets que vous pouvez
imaginer réglementaire de raccordement
physique de la distribution énergétique
etc etc
donc c'est vraiment là je crois
l'exemple l'illustration d'une un
équilibre contractuels opérationnel
partage de la vision avec les sociétés
concessionnaires au service des français
et dans une temporalité très réduite je
crois qu'elle augure
c'était qu'il augure cet équilibre de
blain de biens pardon de belles choses
pour l'avenir
merci quand même soulagé merci la parole
est à monsieur jean pierre corbisez pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
merci mme la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le rapport
de la commission d'enquêté estime que
les dividendes
versé aux actionnaires des concessions
autoroutières atteindrait 40 milliards
d'euros de la 2022 chiffres que vous
contestez
cependant monsieur le ministre la
privatisation de 2006 que vous et nous
héritons aujourd'hui s'est donc faite au
détriment du contribuable
les usagers des autoroutes concédées
mais aussi des usages et des autres
infrastructures de transport et du
désenclavement des territoires
une manne qui aurait pu servir à
financer une bonne partie du rose réseau
routier national non concédé à
désengorger certains axes à entretenir
et développer nos infrastructures
ferroviaires à assumer des
investissements
nous ont fait tant défaut ces dernières
années dans son référé en date du 23
janvier 2019
la cour des comptes a affirmé que
différents pôles divers ce plan de
relance autoroutier décidé en faveur du
réseau autoroutier concédé présente un
risque de surinvestissement qui je le
cite contraste avec le
sous-investissement que nous constatons
aujourd'hui sur le réseau non concédé si
j'adhère totalement à l'acte iii du
rapport de la commission qui vise à
négocier une amélioration du service
rendu aux usagers
outre le verdissement des tarifs des
péages les véhicules les plus propres
les bornes de recharge électrique
j'aimerais même y inclure la réflexion
sur les points de ravitaillement en
hydrogène
il est souhaitable que les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes contribuer
davantage au financement des autres
infrastructures de transport comme cela
avait été décidé timidement 2015
après l'abandon de l'éco taxe poids
lourds qui a constitué un manque à
gagner de plus de 500 millions d'euros
par an pour la fuite
monsieur le ministre comment le
gouvernement entend qu'il optimiser
l'allocation des investissements dans
les infrastructures de transport en les
réorientant prioritairement vers celles
qui sont structurantes pour
l'aménagement du territoire et en
encourageant la transition écologique
dans le domaine des transports journée
merci monsieur le ministre avait la
parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur peut-être deux points d'abord
un point sur la contribution financière
finalement des sociétés concessionnaires
sur le financement ou au financement des
infrastructures gelé rappelé dans le
propos liminaire mais entre 2006 et 2010
8 c'est 50 milliards de recettes
fiscales qui ont été versés par
l'activité les concessions autoroutières
et s'est par ailleurs plus de 10 5
milliards qui ont été versés à lafitte
et cette contribution représentait un
tiers du budget de la fit aux bénéfices
beaucoup d'autres projets y compris des
projets ferroviaires donc je crois que
bien là un caractère vertueux du
financement des modes du mode routier ou
autoroutier en l'occurrence vers
d'autres modes de transport vers nos
petites lignes ferroviaires vers nos
routes nos concédé ou encore nos ponts
le deuxième sujet que vous avez abordé
c'est le sous investissement et à raison
chronique qu'ont subis les réseaux dits
secondaires ou le réseau no concédé
s'agissant de la route
or depuis 2017 et de façon constante
nous avons progressivement autant sur
les nouveaux investissements que sur la
régénération et l'entretien augmenter
son budget pour passer en gros de 700
millions à 1 milliard d'euros et nous
venons de relance et il ya très peu de
semaines un grand projet sur les ponts
connecter pour nous assurer que nous
sommes en capacité de mieux connaître
notre patrimoine est de veiller à ce
qu'ils soient bien entretenu au final
monsieur le sénateur depuis 2007 nous
avons posé une loi des mobilités qui est
équilibré et financé savait parler du
trou de 500 millions d'euros se trouve a
été couvert depuis lors et vous avez vu
que à l'occasion du plan de relance 11
milliards des 100 milliards ont été
consacrés au transport pour répondre à
l'ensemble de ces enjeux de transition
écologique et d'équité de nos
territoires
je crois que nous avons répondu la très
précisément et je crois de façon très
volontaire à votre questionnement
merci monsieur corbisier vous avez 50
souvent merci
la parole est donc à monsieur et reebok
et pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologistes
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le sénat a fait oeuvre utile avec cette
commission d' enquête sur la régulation
des concessions autoroutières et je veux
aussi remercier son rapporteur et son
président mieux qu'un rapport ces
travaux constituent elles un point
d'appui et il est étayée pour mener le
combat permettant le retour de l'état
stratège pour les infrastructures
d'intérêt national et aussi pour
l'aménagement du territoire depuis de
trop nombreuses années ce scandale
perdure sans que rien ne s'oppose au
match ton dos de priver les sociétés
concessionnaires sont de véritables
machines à cash puisque même en temps de
crise même en 2020 les dividendes
s'élève à 2 milliards d'euros entre 2006
et 2010 9 ce sont ainsi 24 milliards
d'euros qui ont été distribués un pognon
de dengue entre guillemets qui aurait
été plus utile pour la solidarité
nationale pourtant les pouvoirs publics
ne sont pas démunis
je souhaiterais ici attirer votre
attention messieurs ministre et avoir
votre avis sur un point précis il s'agit
des obligations reposant normalement sur
le concessionnaire au titre de l'article
31 31-5 du code de la commande publique
concernant notamment l'inventaire du
patrimoine
ce rapport à ma connaissance n'a jamais
été remis à l'autorité concédante et
donc à l'état comment justifier cette
situation comment dans ce cas vous
travaillez à une reprise des concessions
comment comprendre que l'état encore une
fois ne fasse pas respecté son intérêt
et ses droits au nom de l'intérêt public
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je vais essayer de répondre le plus
précisément possible à cette question
technique vous avez raison de dire que
l'investissement ou l'établissement
plutôt de l'inventaire du réseau est non
seulement un enjeu clé indispensable de
se lier à la définition du bon et a
ciblé je viendrai du réseau en fin de
concession tiendra bien un chiffre qui
est important l'occasion de l'évoquer
c'est le chiffre de 150 milliards
d'euros qui est celui qui représente le
patrimoine autoroutier français et à
défaut d'un entretien soigné et régulier
ce patrimoine se détériore à sous
l'action du trafic et des agressions
naturelles et nécessite alors des
travaux de régénération considérable la
rénovation et le renouvellement de ce
patrimoine se planifie donc à l'avancé
requiert des travaux s'étalant sur
plusieurs années dont les
concessionnaires ont la responsabilité
est en amont des fins de concessions
l'action du concédant céder à l'état en
matière de contrôle du patrimoine et de
politique d'entretien doit s'intensifier
fameuse règle muscles aux 17 ans afin
d'éviter qu'un sous-investissement ne se
traduise en dégradation du patrimoine
en fin de contrat depuis plusieurs
années l'état élabore une stratégie et
un plan d'action pour structurer et
renforcer l'efficacité de son
intervention dans le domaine
trois chantiers ont acier était engagé
avec les concessionnaires
il s'agit d'abord de dresser
l'inventaire du patrimoine autoroutier
concédé de définir les outils et les
méthodes permettant de mieux connaître
nos contrôles et ils me suivent l'état
fonctionnel du patrimoine et enfin
d'établir le bon état cible de ce
patrimoine en vue de la préparation de
la fin de contrat comme je l'évoquais
précédemment cet inventaire a été
réalisé pour les ponts de tancarville et
de normandie qui arriveront à échéance
en 2027 et pour lequel les échanges et
les expertises techniques entre
concédant et concessionnaires se sont
déroulées sur près de deux ans entre fin
2018 et me 2020 ils n'ont pas encore été
engagée sur les contrats historiques
c'est la cause de 7 ans s'appliquera et
socialement donc septembre avant les
échéances de 2031 à 2036 et je souhaite
que mon ministère qui disposent des
compétences et des moyens propres
continue d'assurer ses missions qui
s'appuiera le cas échéant sur les
équipes techniques du ctu du cinéma mais
je suis comme vous particulièrement
attaché
à ce sujet important c'est ok vous avez
une minute et sept secondes
la présidente monsieur ni je ne pense
pas avoir entendu le réponse précise à
ce défaut de transmission du rapport
annuel par les concessionnaires à
l'autorité concédante et donc à l'état
tout dans ce dossier en fait est
ubuesque de la conclusion des contrats
aux sous délégation qui favorise les
ententes en passant par la définition du
niveau des péages
dans une étude 2020 deux universitaires
français rappelle l'illégalité des
surcompensations ainsi que de celle du
décret de 1995
indexant les péages sur l'inflation ces
dispositifs pourraient être considéré
soit comme des aides d'état au niveau
européen soit contraire aux règles
définies par le code monétaire et
financier qui pourrait justifier ainsi
une rupture anticipée pour cela il
faudrait une vraie volonté politique
absente malheureusement je le constate
merci la parole et au président jean
françois longeot du groupe union
centriste
mais la présidente monsieur miniter sur
collègues les conclusions de la
commission denquête doivent permettre de
préparer l'avenir c'est sur ce point que
je souhaite vous interroger alors de la
transition écologique on peut regretter
que notre pays sont en retard sur le
passage au péage sans barrières qu'il
est coutume d'appeler le flux libre
en effet l'intérêt d'un modèle est
d'abord écologique un poids-lourd
consommant de litres de carburant
supplémentaire en s'arrêtant un
rendement aux barrières de péage et ce
sont de surcroît autant de surfaces
imperméabilisées qui pourront être
rendues à la nature ce ministère
l'objectif ce modèle de péage du futur
ont été fixées aux concessions
autoroutières dans un second temps comme
vous le savez de nombreux poids lourds
en transit évite les autoroutes et
empruntent des itinéraires parallèles
via les routes nationales ou
départementales en raison de leur
gratuité
or la sur-fréquentation induite par une
telle pratique pose des problèmes de
sécurité de sécurité parfois très
dramatique dégradation évidente des
infrastructures ou encore de nuisances
sonores
sans parler d'une pollution de l'air
accrue tandis que les autoroutes sont
mieux adaptés pour accueillir ses poils
au alors qu'une mission d'information à
l'initiative de la com
ici on d'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable doit prochainement
rendre ses conclusions sur le transport
de marchandises
face aux impératifs environnementaux
quelles sont vos propositions pour
éviter ce report de trafic sur le réseau
secondaire
pourquoi ne pas imaginer un dispositif
sur le modèle des zones à faibles
émissions pour les poids lourds
pensez vous qu'il faille davantage
renforcée dispositif réglementaire en
confortant les arrêtés préfectoraux ou
bien recrute recourir à une éco
contribution régionale telle que prévue
dans le projet de loi climat et
résilience qui sera prochainement
examiné par notre assemblée et je vous
remercie monsieur nice
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur l'enjeu président peut-être de
question du coût de réponse sur les flip
d'abord sur les flux libre pardon
d'abord dire que nous ne sommes pas en
retard sur le sujet nous avons des
expérimentations que vous connaissez
bien sûr trois diffuseurs sur la cades
sur la 837 et sur l'a10 qui je crois
démontre la pertinence d'un tel mode et
le flux libre pour les raisons
écologiques et vous avez parfaitement
cité sera à déployer à grande échelle et
vous le savez en 2022 sur à l'occasion
de la mise en service de la 79 et plus
tard plus tard dans le cadre des
nouvelles concessions et de la
conversion de sections du réseau
actuellement concédé donc nous sommes là
je crois au bon niveau et avec des
expérimentations qui portent leurs
fruits sur le deuxième sujet vous avez
abordé très large je suis à du report
modal notamment des poids lourds il ya
tout ce que nous faisons
autour du report modal vers des modes
plus vertueux par nature je pense
notamment au sujet du fret ferroviaire
et je n'y reviens pas il ya les et des
feux qui sont mises en place sur les
véhicules légers avec vous le savez un
grand de territoire qui sera bientôt
couvert et puis effectivement l'article
32 du projet de loi climat et résilience
permet de donner la possibilité aux
régions situées à une contribution sur
le transport routier de marchandises
c'est une demande des régions à laquelle
nous avons répondu notamment la région
grand est et ile-de-france et
départements pourront également demander
à l'appliquer sur certaines routes
départementales pour éviter les reports
de trafic
les équipes de mon ministère travaille
actuellement
à l'inventaire de ces routes au vu des
demandes actuelles les élus merci
président lugo
merci la parole est à monsieur olivier
jacquin pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai deux
questions sur ce sujet passionnant je
salue les travaux de notre commission d'
enquête qui a bien mis en évidence un
certain nombre de déséquilibres qui
existe entre concédant et
concessionnaires
la première question elle est courte le
décret de 1995 relatif à la fixation
annuelle du prix des péages est il bien
légal dans l'hypothèse d'une abrogation
il y aurait d'importantes conséquences
notre collègue députée christine pires
bonne attend toujours votre question
votre réponse à ces questions écrites je
ne doute pas que je vais l'obtenir
ma deuxième question vient d'être posée
par mon collègue éric bocquet et les
relatif à l'article r 31 31 du code de
la commande publique qui prévoit que le
concédant chaque année publie un rapport
contenant un inventaire précis et
actualisés des biens concédé or cette
obligation n'est pas respectée
pire que ça monsieur le ministre dans
votre courrier du 5 avril au rapporteur
vous écrivez l'enjeu pour le concédant
n'est pas de disposer au cours de la
concession d'un inventaire précis un
instant donné
et cette phrase est totalement contraire
à la doctrine législatives et
réglementaires
vous n'avez pas répondu à mon collègue
et ami éric bocquet
je ne doute pas que j'obtiendrais une
réponse vous avez démarré votre propos
introductif en déclarant que vous
vouliez un meilleur encadrement des
contrats or sur cette question qui n'est
pas que technique monsieur le ministre
on donne les clés aux concessionnaires
et on ne contrôle pas moi je ne veux pas
d'un modèle concessif non contrôlée
merci de vos deux réponses à ces
questions précises
ça merci monsieur le ministre vous êtes
très attendu je vois ça je vois simone
la présidente donc je vais essayer
d'être prêt si monsieur le sénateur vous
ces experts sur ces sujets sur
l'abrogation du décret de 1995 d'abord
savait que il est prévu par dérogation
aux dispositions du droit commun que les
rémunérations des contractants de l'état
au titre des contrats de concession
puisse être indexé sur niveau général
des prix
les travaux parlementaires ayant présidé
à l'adoption de cette dispositif
établissent clairement qu'il s'agissait
surtout de conforter juridiquement la
pratique contractuelle de l'état et des
sociétés concessionnaires de recours un
indice d'évolution plutôt favorables
soit à l'état soit aux usagers en outre
cette modification du code monétaire et
financier avait le mérite de donner une
accroche législatives au décret de 95
sur les péages autoroutiers
cette dérogation ne nécessite pas
forcément de décret d'application pour
ces contrats administratifs
il n'existe donc aujourd'hui plus de
motifs pertinents qui justifierait de
remettre en cause le décret de 1995 sur
le sujet du bon état des infrastructures
de fin de concession j'ai eu l'occasion
de répondre à monsieur le sénateur
bocquet la stratégie de l'état en la
matière est évidemment de structurer le
renforcer son intervention dont le
domaine il s'est agi agit de définir les
bons outils les bonnes méthodes qui
permettent de d'abord de connaître puis
ensuite de contrôler et de suivre l'état
fonctionnel du patrimoine pour établir
le bon état cible venait à cible enfin
deux ans fin de concession rentre pas
dans le times une grille des critères a
été évidemment établi sur le sujet nous
avons déjà fait l'exercice je le disais
pour les deux fonds de tancarville et de
normandie qui arrive à échéance en 2027
et donc l'exercice s'est fait sept ans
avant et c'est bien là dessus que je
parlais de sept buts et calendaires qui
nous permet sept ans avant de préparer
la fin de contrat mais d'une manière
générale la philosophie du ministère
monsieur le sénateur c'est bien de
connaître en tout temps l'activité la
bonne santé des ouvrages
j'ai parlé du plan pont connectés que
nous avons lancé c'est bien la
philosophie qui peut être ses pompes sur
les réseaux concédés ou non concédées
qui consiste à instrumenter les ponts à
connaître leur état de santé à l'instant
t est à prévoir les travaux de façon
beaucoup plus prédictif en fonction de
leur état de vie et des sollicitations
qu'ils encourent voilà la présidente si
monsieur jacques 1 vous avez 32 secondes
je vais faire un remerciement bien sûr
mais 1/2 remerciements un remerciement
je prends acte de la réponse à la
première question relative à la légalité
du décret de 1995
mais je n'ai pas plus de succès qui éric
bocquet sur la réponse au bon état vous
avez répondu à côté je vous ai affirmé
que dans le code de la commande publique
auxquelles nous sommes soumis chaque
année un rapport doit être remis
j'ai affirmé que nous n'avions pas ce
rapport donc comment contrôler le
concédant est le bien public vous ne
m'avez pas contredit sur ce point me
parlant des ponts et d'autres sujets
mais vous n'avez pas ce rapport annuel
comment voulez vous améliorer la
relation avec les concessionnaires
merci monsieur louis jean de nicolay
pour le groupe l'est républicain et s'il
vous plais chers collègues de mettre
correctement votre masque sur le nez
merci beaucoup merci madame la
présidente donne le rappeler madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues plus que le modèle qu'on
sait s'ils sont l'économie générale et
son analyse que mes collègues ont
largement questionner je m'arrete
m'attarderai pour ma part plus
particulièrement sur les considérations
environnementales
en écho à l'urgence actuelle dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons et qui in
fine et saint cyr s'insère dans l'axé 3
qui a été développée au sein de la
commission denquête à savoir négocier
une amélioration du service rendu aux
aux usagers compte tenu de la
rentabilité indiqué dans le rapport
en 1970 la france était confrontée à un
défi de développement économique des
territoires
il s'agissait alors de rattraper notre
retard en matière de desserte des
territoires par le réseau autoroutier et
le gouvernement fait appel au secteur
privé dans la sarthe ce fut un succès et
nous l'avons ceux constatés depuis les
années soixante dix avec tout d'abord la
11 et depuis une vingtaine d'années avec
la 28 5 bronze autoroute irriguent notre
département et ont largement contribué à
sa prospérité modeste économique
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés
à l'urgence climatique et à l'impérieuse
nécessité de décarbonés le secteur des
transports
mais il faut rappeler que la route
assure encore en france 87 % des
déplacements des personnes et 86% du des
du transport des marchandises par
conséquent décarbonés le secteur des
transports
cela signifie tout simplement qu'il faut
décarbonés la route
c'est urgent et on ne peut pas attendre
encore dix ans pour agir
il me semble que nous sommes confrontés
là aux exigences de nécessité et
d'utilité envisagée par la tutelle 122-4
du code de la voirie routière et de la
jurisprudence afférentes
ma question monsieur le ministre est
donc la suivante pensez vous que les
contrats ces sociétés autoroutières qui
avait été pensé dans un objectif au
départ le développement économique
pourrait être rapidement réorienté vers
cet objectif stratégique de
décarbonation et si oui comment vous en
remercie monsieur le ministre ce tabou
merci on a la présidente monsieur le
sénateur
d'abord vous avez raison de dire que les
contrats historiques correspondaient à
des enjeux un tout petit peu différente
qu'à différents l'objectif dans les
années 70 c'était évidemment de
désenclaver les territoires avec des
réseaux qui était peu construit et
d'offrir des infrastructures adaptées
pour un transport rapide et sûr et je
crois que de ce point de vue là le bilan
objectivement et bon 70 ans plus tard
vous avez raison de dire que l'objectif
aujourd'hui en tout cas les enjeux
d'aujourd'hui sont un peu différents il
s'agit évidemment de préserver la
cohésion de nos territoires de procéder
à des investissements utiles pour les
usagers mais aussi de décarbonés nos
routes qui sont l'essentiel vous l'avais
dit à la fois pour les passagers et pour
les marchandises les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre j'ai cité tout à l'heure
le sujet des véhicules électriques comme
un un bon sujet non seulement d'études
mais de déploiement d'une action de
décarbonation d'abord parce que ça
concentrent la plupart plus grande
partie des émissions et ensuite que ça
consiste non seulement pour l'état à
définir les niveaux dead pour
accompagner le secteur de la
construction automobile et je le redis
ici j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire mais
nous avons aujourd'hui 16% des véhicules
vendus cette année qui sont des
véhicules électriques ou hybrides
rechargeables et donc ça montre la
grande dynamique c'est que les états ont
pris
des engagements qui sont
extraordinairement fort et on estime
qu'en 2030 nous aurons 50 % des
véhicules vendus qui seront électriques
pour ce faire il faut effectivement
déployer des infrastructures notamment
des bornes de recharge rapide et c'est
l'enjeu de ce que j'ai annoncé tout à
l'heure en tout cas évoqué les 100
millions consentie ou investis par
l'état dans ses infrastructures
compléter les 500 millions des sociétés
concessionnaires qui je montre là qui
montre là je crois l'ambition conjointe
de l'état et des sociétés
concessionnaires sur ce sujet évidemment
le sujet est un peu plus large le report
modal sur les transports de marchandises
c'est évidemment aussi le sujet du
report sur les modes les plus vertueux
sur le plan environnemental je pense
notamment au fret ferroviaire je n'avais
pas plus large plus loin dans ce sujet
mais vous comprenez que notre action est
large et je crois totalement engagée sur
le sujet merci monsieur nicollin merci
donc la parole est à madame jocelyne
guinness pour le groupe union centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre j'attire votre attention sur la
question des péages urbains et de
l'injustice que leur existence induits
je pense en particulier à certains
péages de la région ile-de-france comme
celui de saint-arnoult qui fut un des
symboles de la crise du gilet jaune ou
encore celui de dourdan que je connais
bien notre réseau autoroutier a été
construit une époque où le développement
périurbain n'avait pas encore atteint
son niveau actuel à une époque où le
recours de l'autoroute pour les trajets
quotidiens entre domicile-travail été
rare depuis d'économie de service c'est
à dire des emplois urbains s'est
considérablement développé par ea comme
sa petite couronne ont attiré de plus en
plus de travailleurs de plus en plus
éloignées en raison notamment de
l'explosion des prix de l'immobilier
résultat ce qui était hier l'exception
est devenue la norme
des dizaines de milliers de franciliens
prennent quotidiennement l'autoroute
pour aller travailler
un grand nombre d'entre eux sont
contraints de payer les péages
périurbain à chaque trajet cette
obligation de payer pour aller
travailler ne touchent pas
nécessairement les plus aisés devant la
commission denquête jean-claude l'argon
président de l'association autoroutes
a10 dont je salue l'engagement indiqué
qu'un travailleur régulier et débourser
1300 euros par an lorsqu'une veulent ou
ne peuvent pas supporter ce coût les
travailleurs pendulaires se reportent
sur le réseau routier secondaire
ce qui n'est pas sans conséquences en
matière d'accident il
accidentalité et de congestion votre
prédécesseur de mme borne avait certes
obtenu un geste des sociétés
d'autoroutes une réduction de 30% pour
plus de dix allers retours par mois sur
le tronçon
ses intentions étaient bonnes
l'opération est un échec sur un million
d'automobilistes prévu à peine cent
mille ont finalement souscrit à
l'abonnement
les concessionnaires on peut communiquer
sur cette offre et le geste n'était pas
suffisant monsieur le ministre
la réponse doit être plus ambitieuse la
suppression de certains péages urbains
en particulier sinus de dourdan serait
une réponse appropriée
comme le souligne la commission denquête
cela n'aboutirait d'ailleurs pas
remettre en cause les équilibres
économiques et financiers de la
concession cofiroute négocier cette
gratuité sans contrepartie tarifaire
répondre à une demande légitime d'équité
merci savez la paroisse de monsieur
ministre merci madame la présidente
nationale trice vous évoquez au fond le
sujet bien connu là aussi des péages
périurbain aux frais de la densification
des zones urbaines et de leur impact sur
le quotidien de leurs usages et
peut-être de prendre réponse sur le
pouvoir d'achat vous avez très justement
rappelé le dispositif qui a été mise en
oeuvre demandés par l'état aux sociétés
concessionnaires à mes temps de baisser
de 30 % les tarifs des usagers
effectuant plus de dix allers-retours
quotidiens par moi pardon ce dispositif
il a connu un début de succès c'était
130 mille abonnements répertoriés avec
une hausse significative entre septembre
2009 et septembre 2020 de 60% et c'est
vrai que la situation propice pour le
coup confinement et au télétravail n'a
pas permis aux dispositifs de de prendre
pleinement son envol j'ai demandé aux
sociétés concessionnaires de se relancer
dans une opération de communication en
ce sens pour soutenir ou le prendre et
le pouvoir d'achat des usagers de la
route sur plus précisément le péage de
dourdan peut-être rappeler ce que j'ai
déjà dit aujourd'hui le tarif d'un euro
77 et c est relativement est
complètement stable et relativement bas
par rapport à d'autres axes routiers que
des formules d'abonnement préférentiels
sont proposés et que des aménagements
temps en place de parking que enfin
notamment en place de parking pour
améliorer l'offre de transport collectif
sur l'a10 a été mise en place
la suppression ou le rachat de ces
péages ne peut être envisagée car cette
suppression fragiliserait à vous le
savez le modèle concessif la section en
question entre dourdan et la folie
bessin de l'a10 est par ailleurs
emprunté par d'autres usagers effectuant
des trajets en transit
originaire ou à destination de la disco
ou de la 11 et social à eux ne paraît
pas aujourd'hui envisagées et
envisageables et le risque serait de
surcroît de reporter une partie du
trafic sur la voirie locale engendrant
d'importantes nuisances et possiblement
de l'insécurité
merci la parole à michel dagbert pour le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains président présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je tiens d'abord à remercier le
président de la commission denquête eric
j'enseigne tasse et son rapporteur
vincent delahaye pour la qualité du
travail effectué dans le cadre de cette
commission enquête
nous ne pouvons en effet que nous
féliciter de la production de ce rapport
qui a permis de mettre en évidence un
nombre de points assez conséquents qui
atteste des conditions pénalisante pour
l'état de la rédaction des convention de
concession
le rapport met en effet en exergue bien
des insuffisances au moment de la
cession des sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes
il apparaît notamment que celle ci n'a
pas été précédée ni d'une révision des
contrats dits historiques ni d'une
définition de l'équilibré qui économique
et financier des dites concession pas
moins non plus de noter qu'une révision
des relations entre
les concessionnaires et l'état concédant
m'a fait l'objet d'une revisite au delà
de la perte des recettes pour l'état
résultant de la privatisation et du
déséquilibre financier de la gestion de
ces concessions autoroutières au profit
des entreprises attributaires
le rapport souligne aussi la permanence
des disparités dans les relations entre
les sociétés concessionnaires du réseau
autoroutier et la puissance publique au
détriment de cette dernière
ceci étant ces concessions ont été
validés dont acte
et la réaction et les mesures qui en ont
découlé atteste que sur le plan
juridique il serait hasardeux de mettre
un terme de façon anticipée à ces
derniers pour autant par voie de
conséquence il s'agira au terme des
concessions de nous donner l'assurance
que vous serez en capacité de faire
l'analyse juridique technique et
financière pour éclairer les choix qui
seront à faire monsieur ministre pouvez
vous nous donner ces garanties sur les
moyens notamment dont vous disposerez à
travers les ingénieries de l'état je
pense notamment aux serema auquel bien
souvent on me minson mais ce n'est ses
ministres vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur peut-être deux points à piles
pour essayer de clarifier le débat entre
nous d'abord dire que l'état connaît
l'état de son patrimoine ses routes ses
ponts on a eu des débats ici sur des
ouvrages et des patrimoines qui était
moins connu raison pour avec les jeux ok
les ponts puisque le faisons un effort
sur notamment le patrimoine des
collectivités territoriales non
seulement pour procéder à l'inventaire
et pour trouver les solutions d'un maire
entretient mais l'état connaît son
patrimoine
il est disponible et l'état connaît par
ailleurs au travers des concessions
l'état du patrimoine routier concédé le
sujet c'était le connaître à la proche
de la fin des concessions raison de la
clause 17 ans de bien connaître à la
proche ou d'avoir un contrôle en force
et à la proche de la fin des concessions
2l'ouvrage des ouvrages et du patrimoine
des concessions pour en gros et je le
dis
très directement ne pas voir un sous
investissement dans les sept dernières
années qui porterait à près ou qui
ferait porter aux finances de l'état
d'éventuels travaux de régénération et
je veux prenez l'exemple du pont de
tancarville et du pont de normandie pour
dire que s'agissant de ces concessions
qui arrive à échéance fin 2020 100 ou en
cet en avant c'est à dire entre 18 et 20
les travaux ont été faits de manière à
bien appréhender l'état de ce patrimoine
et pour finir monsieur le sénateur je
vous confirme que l'état les services de
mon ministère ont les moyens ont les
capacités appuyer comme vous l'avez dit
par d'autres dispositifs qui dispose de
compétences d'ingénierie technique et
financière de très haut niveau comme le
cinéma de mener à bien ses travaux
visant à établir l'état cible du
patrimoine enfin concessions merci la
parole est à monsieur didier mangly pour
le groupe l'est républicain
même la présidente monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues le débat autour des
concessions de tous routière ne cessent
de nous mobiliser
quinze ans après leur privatisation et
comme l'a rapporté notre collègue
vincent de la m
les résultats des sociétés autoroutières
atteignent un niveau élevé cela est lié
il faut le rappeler à leur
professionnalisme et la qualité des
services proposés aux aspects positifs
en matière de sécurité et à leur
capacité reconnue en termes de gestion
cela est dû bien sûr sans doute par
ailleurs aux conditions de la
privatisation et aux négociations qui
apparaissent aujourd'hui assez
avantageuse si le rapport de la
commission denquête rappelle que les
clauses introduite en 2015 ont pu
rééquilibrer les rapports entre l'état
et une mauvaise herbe
il souligne néanmoins que ces clauses
restent pour le moins est inopérante
pour les sociétés historiques cette
situation de défiance menace directement
les projets d'investissement des
sociétés et les éventuels partenariats
avec l'étape
ce sont nos territoires et les usagers
qui pâtissent le plus de cette situation
six ans après ces négociations et fort
du rapport de la commission enquête
il devient urgent de réunir tous les
acteurs et de négocier des clauses
solide durable et en tout cela en toute
transparence à ce titre nous examinerons
prochainement le projet de loi climat il
paraît indispensable comme l'ont
d'ailleurs souligné à sa ronde de
collègues d'exiger davantage
d'implication des sociétés d'autoroutes
sur le développement durable comme une
contrepartie essentiel des contrats de
concession bornes de recharge des
voitures électriques même si vous en
avez rappelé à l'instant les engagements
qu'il est
pris de part et d'autre voie réservée
aux offres de covoiturage plateforme
multimodale de nouvelles négociations
sont à l'envisager monsieur le ministre
pour instaurer de nouvelles clauses à la
fois sur la question financière bien sûr
mais aussi sur les exigences
environnementales
monsieur le ministre c'est un mot merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur en délit peut-être quelques
quelques quelques points distincts
d'abord vous avez rappelé avec
objectivité le bilan notamment en termes
de sécurité de confort d'aménagement du
territoire de ces sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes vous avez
aussi rappelé le meilleur encadrement
depuis 2015 et je n'y reviens pas la
création de l'ertt et notamment qui
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir un contrôle
très précis notamment de l'équipe de l'
équilibre et que économique des contrats
d'édition des partenariats entre l'état
les sociétés et les collectivités
peut-être deux points vous avez cité à
nouveau le sujet des bandes électrique
qui je crois montre bien qu'on sait
mettre en oeuvre des actions concrètes
avec des volumes financiers importants
je le rappelais de façon cumulée et sur
quelques années trois ans ces 600
millions d'euros qui s'auto sont
investis partout sur le territoire avec
aussi l'objectif de ne pas recréer ces
zones grises de la mobilité que nous
avons pu connaître par ailleurs et par
ailleurs quand de certaines
collectivités se sont montrés motrices
sur le sujet nous avons pu signer des
pactes très localisées de relance
autoroutière je pense notamment au pac
nous avons signé avec renaud muselier a
maintenant quelques mois en plus
d'impact sur les petites lignes
ferroviaires s'agissant de l'avenir à
moyen long terme j'ai évoqué notre
disponibilité à participer ou à créer un
sommet des autos qui permettra d'aborder
justement les grands sujets structurants
les modalités de gestion le pilotage
public versus la délégation au privé
et puis de voir comment nous pouvons
mettre en musique c'est en tout cas
comment nous pouvons adresser très
concrètement ces grands enjeux qui sont
écologiques et sociaux et que vous avez
rappelé juste à l'instant sachez que
l'état le gouvernement ce gouvernement
est bien évidemment à la disposition du
parlement pour continuer à avancer sur
ce sujet important
merci monsieur mans délit vous avez 50
et une seconde
merci madame
résidente sait plus qui ne m'en faudra
pour répondre monsieur le ministre pour
lui dire qu'évidemment nous sommes très
intéressés par la création de ce sommet
des autoroutes je souhaiterais pas qu'il
intègre bien sûr la représentation
nationale au travers ben évidemment du
conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures de la fuite mais aussi
directement de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat pour que nous puissions
participer très clairement à ses travaux
en toute transparence je l'évoqué dans
mon propos ça me paraît indispensable à
la fois pour restaurer la confiance
entre l'état et ses partenaires mais
aussi entre les usagers et puis tous
ceux qui sont intéressés par
l'aménagement du territoire ce sont des
infrastructures essentielles à
l'ensemble du territoire national et ça
me paraît important que nous y soyons
associés de très près merci la parole
est à monsieur eric sanitas pour le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
merci madame la présidente mon
interrogation monsieur le ministre est
double et par dessus sur les sous
concessionnaire c'est à dire les aires
de service si les recommandations de la
rt ont permis ces dernières années
d'éclaircir quelques peu les conditions
d'attribution des sous concession par
les sca quelques zones d'ombré
subsistent
des progrès ont été réalisés pour
renforcer l'effectivité de la modération
tarifaire sur le prix des carburants
mais la commission denquête préconise un
renfort des contrôles sur les sous
concession deux mesures nous semble
souhaitable la première serait de
prévoir explicitement que la rt peut
connecter directement auprès des sous
concessionnaire toute l'information
utile pour pouvoir contrôler le respect
des engagements des titulaires
concernant la fixation des prix ou la
durée des sous concession la seconde
serait d'étendre l'obligation de
modération tarifaire aux carburants
alternatifs et de prévoir un suivi
régulier des prix réels des carburants
par les essais à un contrôle de second
niveau serait réalisée par la rt assorti
d'un pouvoir de sanction
cela permettrait à la fois de favoriser
le recours aux carburants alternatifs et
de contrôler le niveau des prix ma
première question monsieur le ministre
est simple comptez vous appliquez ces
deux recommandations
par ailleurs la crise sanitaire a mis en
lumière le rôle des aires de service au
sein du réseau autoroutier ce sont les
sous concessionnaire qui ont par exemple
accueilli les routiers comme les
commerciaux et les autres visages et
pour
puissent se restaurer et se reposer et
bénéficier de structures de confort
notamment en matière d'hygiène
la crise a cependant causé des pertes
importantes sur les magasins la
distribution de boissons chaudes et la
restauration
j'ai été alerté vous aussi monsieur le
ministre dans une société creusoise
limousine donc picoty autoroute qui
compte 25 sous concessions et a ainsi
perdu 1,2 million d'euros sur l'année
2020 dans le même temps les principaux
concessionnaires ont obtenu 2 milliards
d'euros de résultat net et de dividendes
pourtant ces derniers refusent de
compenser le manque à gagner des sous
concessionnaire par des mesures
économiques significatives voici donc ma
seconde question est il envisageable de
mettre en oeuvre un mécanisme de
solidarité exceptionnel entre
concessionnaires et sous concessionnaire
dans le contexte de la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
merci bien la présidente monsieur le
sénateur pour aller droit au but
à la première question les deux répond
son oui puisque nous avons à la fois
bien noté dans le rapport la
recommandation pour que le rôle de
l'arrêté soit renforcée dans le contrôle
des sous concession j'avais deux sujets
que vous avez évoqué je vous confirme
que des discussions sont en cours avec
la rt lieu le cas échéant à des décrets
de manière organisée tout cela mais la
réponse est oui
sur le deuxième sujet eh bien vous avez
raison de dire que les concessions les
sous concessions ont joué un rôle clé au
moment le plus aigu de la crise puisque
vous savez les transporteurs routiers et
les routiers ont fait face dans les
premiers jours à des pénuries de
services essentiels je pense notamment
aux douches aux toilettes au au service
de restauration que tous ensemble nous
nous sommes mobilisés pour les rouvrir
le plus rapidement possible ce qui avait
permis dans les jours qui suivaient de
rouvrir quelques notamment 400 services
de restauration un peu partout dans le
territoire
nous avons bien conscience par ailleurs
des difficultés financières j'ai demandé
à mes services notamment à marc
papinutti qui oeuvre sombre a également
sur tous ces sujets organisé plusieurs
réunions de concertation entre l'as far
et l'asca dont notamment un petit côté
autoroute est membre et ces réunions ont
permis de définir les demandes et les
contraint de partager les contraintes de
chaque secteur et doit maintenant
permettre de faciliter les négociations
contractuelles entre concessionnaires et
sous concessionnaire j'ai bon espoir que
cette situation s'assainissent dans les
semaines les mois qui viennent
merci la parole est à monsieur jean
pierre grand pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci madame la présidente monsieur mise
mais chaque collègue le projet de
contournement ouest de montpellier c'est
à dire le chaînon manquant de 6 km entre
les 750 et 2 709 présente un caractère
hautement prioritaires l' enquête
publique s'est déroulée en 2020 le
commissaire enquêteur a rendu le 22
septembre dernier un avis favorable des
huées
sous réserve de son financement qui
reste bien sûr à finaliser
ici même avoir entendu défendre
plusieurs fois le principe du
financement de ce projet par un
adossement à la concision asf
ce mode de financement présente un
triple avantage il ne coûte rien à
l'état rien aux collectivités locales
qui toute façon pas les moyens de
financer rien à l'usagé puisque le
tronçon sera gratuit dans ce dossier mon
interrogation est grande sur notre
capacité et notre volonté a dépassé les
polémiques infondées les log machisme
archaïque pour regarder la vérité en
face et prendre de bonnes décisions
l'importance économique de la mise en
oeuvre de ce dossier de plus de 300
millions d'euros
nous sommes s'intégrer parfaitement dans
le plan de relance et de l'aménagement
de notre territoire nous pourrions
participer partager la conviction que
pour sortir de la crise actuelle aux
conséquences terrifiantes pour les
finances publiques
notre pays aura besoin de repos et de
recourir à l'investissement privé pour
faire aboutir des projets
d'infrastructures en particulier
routière la concession est un cadre qui
a largement démontré ses avantages la
déclaration d'utilité publique du cob
doit être signé un seul ministre début
septembre 2021
le seul ministre aux rivaux d'ici là
acté son adossement à la concession asf
seule et unique solution pour son
financement et donc sa réalisation
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
merci madame la présidente sociaux
nature grands vous avez rappelé les les
principaux éléments du projet du
contournement ouest de montpellier
c'est avec le coût total du projet est
estimé à 280 millions d'euros à ce stade
et que certains crédits des crédits ont
été engagés pour 25 millions d'euros
dans le cpr 2015 2020
ce projet connu il a fait l'objet de
nombreux échanges depuis de nombreuses
années mais la métropole de montpellier
a décidé de se désengager du financement
du projet demandant un adossement total
à la concession autoroutière existantes
par conséquent la demande du premier
ministre nous avons lancé une étude fine
des conditions de l'adossement du
contournement ouest qui posent de vraies
questions de droit et qui
vraisemblablement nous rendra nécessaire
la saisine du conseil d'état pour les
résoudre
je connais bien votre position j'ai bien
pris connaissance des éléments que vous
avez transmis et je vous en remercie
les travaux de notre côté se poursuivre
évidemment assidûment et l'ensemble des
acteurs locaux seront informés dans les
semaines qui viennent pour tenir compte
notamment des échéances que vous avez
situé en septembre pour la déclaration
d'utilité publique soyez assuré monsieur
sénateurs de notre plein investissement
sur ce sujet merci monsieur grand vous
avez 54 secondes
même la présidente pour rappeler que ce
dossier ne semblent pas il ne paraît pas
devoir poser de problème 6 km 6 km ça ne
m'est pas par dessus tête la concession
de l'autoroute a9 qui je le rappelle la
concession se termine en 2031
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que de voir le gouvernement
signé la dlp avant le début du mois de
septembre celui-ci vous en remercier je
suppose que le conseil d'état aura toute
la sagesse que nous le connaissons pour
aller dans le sens de l'intérêt général
merci la parole est à mme effet patrick
chaize pour le groupe l'africain un
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues les concessions
autoroutières ont fait l'objet d'une
contractualisation entre l'état à des
sociétés privées en prenant en compte
des prévisions de dépenses et de
recettes pour la durée du contrat
c'est d'ailleurs la règle de base de
tout contrat concessif là il est
également de faire en sorte que le
risque soit assumée par l'entreprise
privée
néanmoins nous avons pu regretter le
concept d'adossement qui a consisté à
étendre les investissements non prévue
initialement au contrat en les
compensant d'un allongement de la durée
la conception initiale
ce principe a pour inconvénient majeur
de transformer le contrat pourtant très
précis à binh
shaw un sentiment de concessions
perpétuelles difficilement explicables
et de moins en moins acceptable par nos
concitoyens
si les extensions de réseau peuvent être
mieux maîtrisées et faire l'objet de
procédures spécifiques certains autres
investissements nécessaires ne peuvent
pourtant pas être dissociée du contrat
je pense notamment à l'intégration des
évolutions technologiques tels que le
développement des véhicules électriques
et l'impérieuse nécessité de disposer
sur le réseau autoroutier de bornes de
recharge rapide plus encore
comment pourra-t-on à intégrer les
investissements nécessaires au
déploiement des véhicules connectés
outre le besoin des choix technologiques
partagé entre tous les acteurs
les montants d'investissements
nécessaires sont loin d'être
négligeables
l'urgence est pourtant là il serait
irresponsable de repousser au terme des
contrats les décisions d'investissements
correspondant aussi je souhaiterais
monsieur le ministre vous puissiez
m'éclairer sur ces points je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le sénateur chose merci pour
cette question je reviens pas sur la
première partie de la question je crois
que nous avons très largement débattu du
modèle de l' équilibre économique et
puis nous sommes en capacité maintenant
nous projeter sur l'avenir de ce que
seront les concessions peut-être que je
reviens sur un sujet important pour mes
sujets les bornes électriques j'en ai
dit un mot twitter je crois pouvoir dire
que nous sommes au bon niveau de
financement et au bon niveau
d'avancement
ce qui est important pour accompagner
notamment le secteur automobile français
et européen revient peut-être d'un
instant sur finalement l'intelligence et
la capacité à faire advenir le véhicule
connecté et donc l eau doter des
infrastructures de connectivité le long
de nos routes pour vous dire que nous ne
sommes pas en retard que nous avons
depuis 2014
plusieurs projets pilotes que le
ministère des transports a ainsi investi
14 millions d'euros dans différents
projets qu'ils coordonnent et qu'au
total pour la france cette période ces
44 millions d'euros qui ont été investis
en sept ans ce qui permet d'avoir 3000
km de réseau routier actuellement
équipés l'unité de bord de route pour
simplement pour le dire simplement pour
échanger des données avec l'idée
d'équiper à horizon 2024
environ 5000 km de routes équipés par
ailleurs et c'est important la france
préside la plateforme six roads europe
qui pilote le groupe technique qui
permettra de développer les principales
spécifications techniques et jusqu'à
présent 95 % des spécifications français
surprise au niveau européen ce qui est
une satisfaction est évidemment une
terre d'opportunités et que ces projets
sont donc mises en place dans le cadre
des concessions actuelles sans
prolongation et qu'à la fin des
concessions d'autoroutes continueront
donc d'être à la pointe de l'innovation
je crois que nous pouvons retrouver nous
retrouver sur cette ambition
conjointement les sénateurs merci
monsieur le ministre mais ces gestes
vous avez 56 secondes
merci madame la présidente monsieur me
disent merci pour ces informations
importantes vous l'avez compris je suis
très sensible à cette évolution
technologique qui d'un point de vue
environnemental aura bien sûr des
conséquences
faut-il encore que effectivement on
puisse avoir des informations pour
pouvoir faire en sorte qu en fin de
contrat des choses soient donc
transparente et je crois que c'est une
demande unanime que vous avez pu
entendre ici dans ce débat donc la
transparence et la règle de base et de
gages même d'une bonne confiance merci
merci la parole et à monsieur jean
raymond ligonnet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président messieurs leur apportant
monsieur le ministre à l'instar de ma
collègue jocelyne guide s qui s'est
exprimée précédemment et du rapporteur
de notre commission denquête vincent de
l'est je suis sénateur du département de
l'essonne et notre présence commune ne
doit certainement rien au hasard
en effet nous militons depuis de
nombreuses années pour la gratuité des
transports franciliens des autoroutes
a10 et à 11
le périmètre de notre action est certes
limité mais parfaitement car acheter
caractéristiques et solidaire d'une
problématique de dimension nationale
depuis près de vingt ans de multiples
études ont dressé un constat souvent
accablant des rapports entre l'état et
les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroutes pourtant rien n'a bougé ou
presque
heureusement ce rapport de la commission
d' enquête sénatoriale confirme avec
pertinence une situation de plus en plus
inacceptable et esquisse de potentiel
réponse car ce débat doit déboucher
enfin sur des mesures significatives en
40 ans dans nos territoires
périphériques france il
l'étalement urbain a provoqué un
triplement de la population durant la
même période les investissements en
transport collectif ont été quasiment
exclusivement concentrée dans le coeur
de l'agglomération
or l'offre de transport collectif s'est
dégradée inexorablement pour la deuxième
couronne francilienne sur laquelle la
funeste loi allure veut continuer
d'entasser de façon aveugle et
kafkaïenne toujours plus de logement
de ce fait les autoroutes péri urbaines
ont dorénavant un rôle structurant pour
les déplacements du quotidien notamment
les trajets domicile travail
pourquoi alors ne pas supprimer les
péages sur les tronçons concédés des
autoroutes périurbaines à commencer par
les plus cyniques d'entre eux sur l'a10
et la 11 en ile de france
pour financer cette disposition de ses
ministres deux propositions
l'application de la clause de
plafonnement de la rentabilité des
concessions issus du protocole de 2015
mais jamais mise en oeuvre
l'instauration d'une taxe sur les copies
aux dividendes versés par les sociétés
concessionnaires
monsieur le ministre que pensez vous de
ces deux propositions monsieur le
ministre c'est à vous merci ma
présidente monsieur le sénateur ont
d'abord dire que nous connaissons bien
ce sujet nous l'occasion de l'évoquer à
de nombreuses reprises je vais pas
redire en détail ce que j'ai répondu
tout à l'heure à votre collègue
simplement et nous avions partagé les
contraintes de la fragilisation du
modèle concessif de l'emprunt par
d'autres usagers que ceux qui habitent
qui se travaille en proximité du péage
de tournant et nous avions partagé aussi
la contrainte que la suppression
risquerait de voir se reporter sur la
voie locaux locale un trafic de
contournement peut-être pour nous
projeter dans l'avenir des pistes
d'amélioration sont évidemment à étudier
je suis pas en mesure de répondre à
votre question aujourd'hui mais nous
aurons à continuer ces débats des
améliorations sont à étudier je le
disais sur le trafic des poids lourds
qui pourraient se reporter sur la voirie
locale
je l'évoquais également la contribution
poids lourd régional que nous proposons
dans le cas de l'article 32 de la loi
climat résidence permet au département
de se saisir de la possibilité d'étendre
la contribution aux axes départementaux
sujet à un report de trafic et je crois
savoir que c'est une possibilité étudiée
en
de france est par ailleurs d amour d
aménagement pardon sur les voiries
départementales sont aussi envisageables
pour améliorer la sécurité et la
fluidité des circulations en traverser
des zones habitées je reste sur tous ces
sujets monsieur le sénateur évidemment à
votre disposition pour échanger et
trouver les voies d'un avenir plus
ensoleillé merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur ghosn et vous avez 34 secondes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous êtes le neuvième depuis 20
ans que je suis élu à travailler donc je
vous remercie de votre disponibilité de
vos réponses
je voulais juste te rapporter quelques
chiffres le taux de profitabilité des
sociétés concessionnaires qui s'établit
à plus de 30% les dividendes versés à
leurs actionnaires qui dépassent
amplement leur résultat net
la crise sanitaire les affects manière
marginalement puisque par exemple entre
2019 et 2020 la profitabilité de
cofiroute est passé de 31,6 à 35,9 pour
cette même société le versement de
dividendes a correspondu à 115 % du
résultat net de grâce monsieur le
ministre
soyez celui qui va faire bouger les
choses nous vous en remercions par
avance metz alors pour conclure le débat
la parole est à tout président vincent
delahaye et rapporteur de la commission
denquête et pour cinq minutes chers
collègues
merci madame la présidente
merci monsieur le ministre d'avoir
consacré une heure et demie à notre
rapport je regrette un petit peu que le
format du débat dans l'hémicycle ne
permettent pas d'aller au fond des
choses et on l'a vu sur un certain
nombre de questions et j'avais pour ma
part fait une demande au président lugo
qui n'a pas pu rester avec nous mais je
lui avais demandé à ce que il vous
sollicite pour qu'il puisse y avoir une
audition en commission de façon à ce
qu'on puisse échanger un peu plus
pauvres de façon un peu plus approfondie
sur ce rapport et moi je reste demandeur
de cette audition
pour aller plus loin alors dans ce débat
il ya des choses qu'on a entendues il ya
des choses qu'on n'a pas entendu et puis
il ya des choses qu'on aurait aimé
entendre alors dans ce que j'ai entendu
de votre part c'est d'abord un ni ni un
ni renationalisation ni prolongation
même s'il ne nie prolongation était un
peu plus timide que le nid
renationalisation
mais j'ai entendu une ligne j'ai entendu
préparation du futur meilleur
encadrement des contrats modernisation
de ses contrats tant mieux parce que ici
y'a pas de concessions bashing est en
tout cas notre rapport n'est pas une
concession bashing on n'a pas moi je ne
suis absolument pas opposé et je pense
qu'on est majoritaire non pas opposé au
principe de la concession de délégation
de service public ça a une efficacité il
ya beaucoup de sociétés et notamment
dans les sociétés d'autoroutes sont des
sociétés importantes ces sociétés
françaises qui sont compétentes qui ont
de la qualité
donc ya pas de raison d'avoir une
concession bashing par contre quand on
concède un service il faut bien le
suivre
et ça c'est très important je pense
qu'il ya eu des progrès considérables de
fait depuis 2015
mais il y a encore beaucoup à faire
notre collègue bocquet n'est pas là mais
tout à l'heure il a bien fait avec notre
collègue chacun de poser la question sur
les rapports d'inventaire parce que
c'est rapport d'inventaire ils devraient
ils sont prévues dans les contrats et on
ne les a pas vous avez vous même reconnu
qu'on les avait pas visiblement et ils
devaient ils doivent être mises à jour
tous les cinq ans donc c'est pas normal
c'est pas normal qu'on puisse pas avoir
ces rapport d'inventaire qui était prévu
dès le départ et qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne les a donc d'accord pour la
concession mais d'accord pour un suivi
rigoureux de ces concessions alors
ensuite il ya un deuxième aspect au delà
de l'inventaire scellé sous concession
moi je pense qu'il ya une grosse
faiblesse sur le suivi des sous
concession notre commission denquête n'a
pas eu le temps d'aller suffisamment
loin dans ce domaine là mais je pense
que ça sera un domaine qu'il faudrait
investiguer un petit peu plus parce que
on entend des sociétés qui ont du mal à
pouvoir rentrer dans ses sous concession
et on se demande un peu pourquoi donc la
nécessité d'avoir de la transparence sur
le sujet et puis pas contre moi j'ai
l'impression quand même que les études
sur la rentabilité des concessions
d'autoroutes la font vraiment l'objet
d'un bashing de la part des sociétés
d'autoroutes l'autorité de la
concurrence en 2013 la cour des comptes
ensuite le rapport du sénat on se
demande s'ils l'ont lu d'ailleurs parce
que en fait comme réponse on a une
réponse d'eiffage
les autres ne nous ont pas répondu et
nous avons tenu compte des observations
des d'eiffage donc on a refait nos
calculs à en tenant compte de ses
observations et nous avons une méthode
qui est basé sur le la rentabilité
interne par rapport aux actionnaires
donc effectivement à l'investissement
initial ou cher collègue claire mais des
vielles qui tous deux leur parler ça
nous sommes bien partis sur cette
méthode là et en revanche la rt lui part
sur une rentabilité projet et ne donne
pas les éléments pour qu'on puisse
contrôler son travail
je suis désolé moi j'aime beaucoup la
rtg j'aimerais bien qu'il soit
transparent
c'est dire que les valeurs d'actifs
qu'ils ont évaluée qu'elles soient
communiquées ces valeurs d'actifs
aujourd'hui on ne les a pas alors on a
des taux de rentabilité qui sont
calculées sur une base qu'on ne connaît
pas donc moi j'aime bien la transparence
et j'apprécie la transparence
je pense que l'alerté a un rôle à jouer
dans ce domaine des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes mais il
faut vraiment que on travaille tous
ensemble et c'est pour ça que si vous
souhaitez j'ai entendu dans votre bouche
que vous souhaitiez mettre en place ce
sommet des autoroutes
moi je souhaite qu'on aborde cette
question de la rentabilité et pas
uniquement des futurs contrats
c'est important de travailler sur les
futurs contrats sur l'évolution des
tarifs sur le verdissement des tarifs
tout ça c'est très important mais la
rentabilité c'est fondamental parce que
quand notre collègue grand évoque le
contournement de montpellier
asf la fin de la concession c'est pas
2031 c'est 2036 mon cher collègue
donc ça nous donne quinze ans et les
prévisions que nous avons publié parce
que moi qui savait écouter les sociétés
d'autoroutes ont de publier 0 prévisions
elles les ont donnés à la rtg une
communication mais s'étaient couverts
par ce cas les affaires et monsieur le
ministre je vous donne en confidence je
peux vous dire que les prévisions que
nous avons publiés dans le rapport sont
en ligne avec celles des sociétés
d'autoroutes
c'est simplement cette information je
vais vous donner et je remercie tous les
participants à ce débat et j'espère que
nous en aurons d'autres pour pas aussi
notre discussion notre travail en commun
merci chers collègues
[Musique]